vamos a hacer una pequeña revisión sobre
los conceptos de contango y mercado
invertido porque realmente son cosas
opuestas y si se usan en diferentes
contextos a veces se tiene un
significado diferente de significado
correcto y vamos a calificar de qué es
lo que estamos hablando si ustedes
escuchan de algún negociante de materias
primas que dice que el mercado está en
contango normalmente se refiere que
existe una curva de precios futuros que
va hacia arriba a lo que normalmente
ustedes ven como una curva de precios
que van hacia la alta se le llama
contango y si escuchan decir algún
negociante de materias primas que dice
que el mercado está invertido están
hablando simplemente de una curva de
precios futuros invertida de ahí el
nombre algo parecido a esto pero si
queremos ser muy precisos eso que les
mencioné se usa en la terminología
cotidiana pero para ser más precisos si
alguien les está diciendo y aquí estamos
hablando de la teoría de contango en
este contexto van a hablar de la noción
de que los precios de entrega en el
futuro están por encima del precio
esperado en esa fecha futura
el problema con esto es que se trata de
una teoría no hay forma de saber con
anticipación cuál es el precio o cuál
fue el precio esperado en el futuro de
manera similar si alguien les dice que
el mercado se encuentra invertido con
respecto a la teoría del mercado
invertido y en este caso se usa la
palabra mercado invertido normal que es
la teoría del mercado invertido en este
caso se refieren a la idea de que el
precio de entrega futuro va a estar por
debajo de algún precio esperado y esto
es debido a que los vendedores están
dispuestos a hacer un gran descuento
para asegurar sus precios pero
nuevamente esto es algo muy teórico no
se puede probar directamente en la
práctica porque en este momento no
sabemos cuál es el precio esperado en el
futuro así que cuando alguien dice que
está el mercado invertido está hablando
de esta curva de precios futuros
invertida y si alguien habla sobre el
mercado invertido normal hablan de la
idea de que el precio futuro de entrega
está por debajo del precio esperado yo
incluso he escuchado el término
con tango normal y es cuando hablan de
la teoría del contango la idea de que un
precio futuro de entrega va a estar por
encima del precio esperado en el futuro
la teoría del contango es opuesta a la
teoría del mercado invertido ahora para
ambas teorías ustedes no saben cuál es
el valor de este precio esperado futuro
así que no lo pueden observar
directamente lo más cercano que podemos
hacer para observar cualquiera de estas
dos teorías para observar un contango
real en el mercado o un mercado
invertido es que por ejemplo en el
contango si y sólo si el precio de
entrega futuro ahora es mucho mayor del
esperado lo podemos ver que conforme se
acerca la fecha de entrega este precio
de entrega se va a ir acercando cada vez
más hasta el valor del precio esperado
debe ir a la baja cuando este precio
baja conforme nos vamos acercando a la
fecha de entrega lo mismo se aplica para
el mercado invertido la única forma que
podemos comprobar que está existiendo un
mercado invertido normal es observar qué
es lo que pasa con el precio de entrega
futuro conforme va pasando el tiempo
este precio de entrega futuro va a ir
aumentando conforme pasa el tiempo hasta
alcanzar el precio esperado la curva de
este precio en el tiempo se va a ir
hacia arriba va a ir aumentando cuando
observamos ese comportamiento de un
precio futuro que va aumentando conforme
pasa el tiempo tenemos que ser la mejor
manera de observar que el mercado está
experimentando un mercado invertido
normal espero que esto haya aclarado los
conceptos